se están negociando sobre un alto al
fuego temporal en un momento en que la
guerra continúa en ucrania ahora mismo
la ciudad de quier de la capital del
país se encuentra bajo un toque de queda
y esta madrugada barrios residenciales
de esta ciudad han vuelto a ser objeto
de bombardeos por parte del ejército
ruso y también preocupa la situación de
mariupol a esta ciudad portuaria ubicada
en el sur del país que desde hace días
es asediada por el ejército ruso pues
sólo hay si solo pocas personas han
logrado escapar
ha logrado utilizar esos corredores
humanitarios de los que hemos hablado
mucho en estos pasados días y según las
autoridades ucranianas también hay 400
médicos y sanitarios de un hospital de
estas ciudades que siguen estando o
siguen como rehenes